voilà monsieur bonsoir nous allons bien
sûr en venir rapidement aux conclusions
politiques du voyage de monsieur
gorbatchev en france mais auparavant je
voudrais vous parler de ce qui restera
peut-être comme l'un des vrais points
forts de cette visite
le nouveau style du dirigeant du kremlin
vif alerte n'esquivant pas les questions
même les plus embarrassants mais aussi
celui de son épouse raïssa gorbatchev
qui elle non plus ne correspond pas du
tout aux clichés qui étaient les nôtres
jusqu'à presse pour vous en persuader
regardez ce reportage que vous ne verrez
nulle part ailleurs
il a été réalisé cet après midi chez le
grand couturier yves saint laurent par
jean-marc il use et bernard puis se sont
trahis sa maxime aubenas gorbatchev
épouse et arme secrète du secrétaire
général du parti communiste soviétique
pour séduire l'europe et convaincre
l'occident
il faut aussi savoir charme et
économisez votre pellicule lance-t-elle
au photographe américain venu détailler
la nouvelle rivale de nancy reagan
en matière d'élégance les grands
couturiers ont paraît-il des petits
secrets qui compte robe noire très
apprécié
émotions fortes pour messieurs les
gardes du corps
on dispose de fort peu d'éléments
biographiques sur la première dame du
rss on sait seulement qu'elle a
rencontré son époux à l'université de
moscou où l étudier la philosophie
comprendre le marxisme léninisme
pour l'heure ces pantalons paraît-il ne
se porteraient guerre à moscou mais
tailleurs et robes longues ou eu les
faveurs de madame gorbatchev et yves
saint laurent et déjà invité à moscou
davantage à côté